[Music]
all right we are almost out of time give
it up for my band y'all real
quick we are almost out of time but
there's just enough for one more great
story this is what I'm
liking check out this adorable stuffed
elephant come on her name is baby chabba
and she's named after a real life
Elephant in Thailand um the real baby
Chaba was rescued from abuse thanks to
the efforts of many activists including
California mama who created this doll
and proceeds from this plushy are
helping rescue even more elephants which
is so cool let's get this super mama in
here say hi to Christina watching on kby
and the lovely Santa Barbara what's up
Christina H thanks so much for having me
hi so how long have you been doing this
work so I started over 20 years ago I
actually saw a baby elephant being
abused in the streets of Thailand and
this is before social media or anything
like that so so I was distru by it and I
was like I can't not unsee this once you
see something like that so I came back
from Santa Barbara and I started
protesting circuses and signing
petitions but it just it just didn't
feel like enough and I think when you
have a calling so strongly like this you
you have to do something and so I saw my
daughter's one day playing with um
stuffed animals and I decided to use my
background in product development and
design and create a stuffed animal to
help raise funds and awareness for them
so
um that was kind of my goal I knew that
the girls were kind of the most affected
by the the abuse and I really wanted to
to teach children everywhere that one
person can make a difference and that we
all need to be the voice for the
voiceless absolutely and when you see
something you can be part of the change
to make that happen I love that so this
is also about educating everybody but
including kids right yeah definitely I I
think it's so important to teach the the
younger generation and so I'm you know
it started just as a a philanthropic toy
company but I've started to teach
children in Africa about how it's so
important to be friendly to the
elephants and nice to them and why it's
important for their environment and it's
so important to teach them that um
elephants are really emotional creatures
that's the book I wrote for Lu Cher with
my friend um Pedro De La Cruz here in
Santa Barbara but I wanted people
everywhere to know that we shouldn't
ride them or exploit elephants and um I
thought i''d start with the children and
I'm super grateful for the momentum and
all the support oh man this is
incredible work you're doing and so
important because a lot of times we do
see things and we don't know what to do
so it's important to know that you can
actually be a part of like positive
change and I think it's smart to start
with the kids because then at a very
young age they learn our respect for
animals um and then you know maybe don't
become the the adults that we have
around us today sometimes um so teach
them to be better than us thank you so
much Christina I'm liking your post
right now I love little
Chaba and that's not all our season long
partner pilot pin makers of G2 the go-to
pin of the Kelly Clarkson show want to
honor truly Unstoppable people just like
you ma'am so they're going to be riding
you a check for $1,000 to use to
continue your incredible
work thank you so much for joining us
from the lovely Santa Barbara that place
is so awesome but thank you to all our
guests this hour as well Taylor and
Taylor lner Alex aser oie wind Jackie
and Jay Brown y'all have a great day and
if it's not try and change it
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home